retrouvez bien sûr camille combal à
l'aller à lézinnes vous allez jouer avec
bernard montiel et nora vous avec gilles
verdez vous allez prendre un petit peu
d'eau vous allez prendre beaucoup dont
beaucoup d'eau dans la bouche un bien
sûr alors on va faire un blind test on
va voir qui va gagner entre enora et
nolwenn attention c'est laisser les
miens 20 ans se met alors vous allez
jouer également sur honda non plus que
ça plus le seront ils en font vider
l'eau il en faut beaucoup il en faut
plus
david lui peut-être ce qu'il vaut mieux
pas le mettre dans le nez de gilbert est
allé alors attention dès que vous avez
la bonne réponse vous presser comme ça
si pauline inquiétez pas il faudra alors
attention premier titre c'est parti
jamais
au canada n'est pas possible
l'aloe non mais c'est pas puisque c'est
parti vous excusez nous excuser mort le
suit désormais la meinau on fut alors
c'est quoi la réponse c'est c'est pas le
bagad de saint bagaza bagad de quimper
et c'est un bagad an c'est un fait c'est
pas du tout ça
jack et des mines est donc allé vous
pouvez alors voilà
alouettes est d'accord pour vous non
loin de mettet boulaouane vous fait
l'animatrice d'accord excusez mais voilà
nolwenn voilà vous avez la liste
d'hôpitaux
merci bas c'était cgt santiano hugues
aufray accepté l'intro soutien
avec un bagage attention à l'est il en a
mis beaucoup
pour l'eau les deux parce que jamais si
vous ne savez pas vous n'appuyez pas
parce qu'il aura la pression sur aucun
rapport avec l'eau prenait genre plus
froides et en plus pour des non plus
mais les dégâts la taille avant la
musique on y va il est passé de ma
musique
et
c'est un amateur adorateurs
le coup de coin
allez on arrête ce jeu là c'est au bar
de poix-terron dans la tête de ces
bombes sont de loin la la la la
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible ça
arrive c'est pas vrai et quant à john
deere et quand celui-ci leverdez je
savais que j'avais fait une bêtise
galeno gerry qui sort du grand bois mais
c'est pas possible ce dernier si la
droite est bien c'est qu'il ya vraiment
que chez toi qu'on fait ça mais je vous
dis je
au début je croyais pas ce jeu qu'on l'a
trouvé ça finalement
étonnamment il est pas mal on est en
train de perdre si vous êtes trop vous
vous êtes fait toujours tourner